a maquette clamp cotton bar was supposed
to be her party's political future
soon she will belong to its past her
hopes of being her country's second
female Chancellor dashed by a Rao over
how her party deals with the far-right
javadi Potiphar's it's nourish Ben I'm
the party leader and I'll remain in this
position for the foreseeable future what
I've said is that I will not run for
Chancellor but other than that the
situation hasn't changed but the
situation certainly has changed and it
was this moment that brought her down
when Christian Democrats joined forces
with the far-right afd to elect a
Liberal prime minister in the state of
Thuringia thereby our sting a popular
far left government and breaking a taboo
which has stood virtually since the AFD
began life seven years ago prompting
protesters onto the streets in that
state and drawing denunciations from all
the main political parties many accused
camp Karen bar of a lack of leadership
accusations which had dogged her since
her election as head of her party in
2018
but it was perhaps the reaction of
Angela Merkel which made cramp Karen
Bauer's decision inevitable late last
week she called what took place in
Thuringia unforgivable here in Berlin on
Monday she was in more conciliatory mood
she company for send us the sunlit calm
calm or I regard this decision with
great respect though I greatly regret it
I can imagine this wasn't an easy
decision for her and I thank her for
being prepared to stay on to steer the
process of choosing a successor for some
Christian Democrats this is the person
to choose pleaded a mouth once on
friendly terms with Merkel but who she
sidelined many years ago he fought his
way back from the political wilderness
and ranan camp Gothenburg close in the
leadership election of 2018 whoever
actually will succeed akk has to make a
decision either as she tried to do so to
bridge that gap or to lead the way in
one of the at one of the two camps and
directions either the America direction
for a more moderate liberal cause or
actually for the freak maths direction
to become much more conservative and
they had been before
then there is the question of what to do
about the AFD in the federal parliament
their numbers are too small to be more
than an irritant to the mainstream
parties but out in the state
Parliament's particularly in the East
they are much more numerous and now they
are raising their voice many Germans are
deeply worried by what they're hearing
Dominic Kane al-jazeera Berlin